My name is Ashe.
我的名字叫阿什。
I'm from Houston, Texas.
我来自得克萨斯州休斯敦。
How I met your mother means comfort to me.
《老爸老妈浪漫史》对我来说意味着慰藉。
2009 I lost my very young mom, 37 years old, to a very rare form of cancer.
2009年，我因一种非常罕见的癌症失去了我年轻的母亲，她当时只有37岁。
And in turn I lost everyone that I called family.
随之我也失去了所有我称之为家人的人。
So 20 year old me, very lost, very confused, and very alone had this show.
所以20岁的我，非常迷茫、非常困惑、也非常孤独，却有这部剧陪着。
Being able to connect with characters and feel a comfort.
能够与角色产生共鸣并感受到一种慰藉，
that I hadn't felt since my mom had been around, meant so much to me and really did help me grow as a person.
这种自我母亲去世后再也没有感受过的慰藉，对我的意义极其重大，并且确实帮助了我作为个人的成长。
I've carried this show with me throughout my adulthood.
这部剧一直伴随着我度过了整个成年期。
Now I am 36 and it really means a lot.
现在我36岁了，它真的意义非凡。
I actually got a chance to see one of Josh's shows in Houston a few years back, which was also very comforting and brought that same feeling back.
几年前，我甚至有机会在休斯敦观看了乔伊的其中一场演出，那同样非常温馨，把那种感觉又带回来了。
I'm so grateful that you're doing this podcast and I am entirely grateful for how I met your mother.
我非常感激你们在做这个播客，我也由衷地感激《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
I'm alone, all be soon.
我孤身一人，很快就会团聚。
You're New York City, when I see you.
纽约城啊，当我看到你。
Please permit me to tell you everything in New York City.
请允许我对你倾诉在纽约城的一切。
Well, hello out there listeners and watchers and fans of how I met your mother.
那么，收听、收看以及喜爱《老爸老妈浪漫史》的朋友们、听众们、粉丝们，大家好。
Welcome to How We Made Your Mother, I'm Josh Radner.
欢迎来到《我们是如何创造老爸老妈浪漫史的》，我是乔什·拉德纳。
I played Ted Mosby for nine seasons on How I Met Your Mother.
我在《老爸老妈浪漫史》中饰演了九季的泰德·莫斯比。
I am joined by my friend Craig Thomas who co-created the show with Carter Bays.
和我一起的是我的朋友克雷格·托马斯，他与卡特·贝斯共同创作了这部剧。
Hi Craig.
嗨，克雷格。
Hey Josh.
嗨，乔什。
How's it going?
最近怎么样？
I, every time Alec, you make me cry with these openings of the show.
艾利克，每次你用这些开场白，都让我感动得想哭。
What a beautiful story.
多美的一个故事啊。
Thank you, Ash.
谢谢你，阿什。
Thank you for sharing that with us.
谢谢你与我们分享这些。
I think when you're in, when you're in grief and something makes you laugh or someone makes you laugh, you almost always forget it.
我想，当你处于悲伤之中时，如果有什么事能让你笑出声，或者有人能让你笑，你几乎永远都不会忘记。
There's something about the, so anything that can, I don't know, alleviate a kind of heavy moment with some lightheartedness.
某种程度上……因此，任何能用轻松愉快的心情来缓解这种沉重时刻的事情，
You feel grateful and loyal to that thing forever.
都会让你永远对它心怀感激和忠诚。
That sounds like what we were able to provide for her.
听起来这就是我们能够为她提供的东西。
Yeah, it's amazing.
是的，这太惊人了。
I mean, I can't imagine how hard that was to at such a young age to go through that.
我的意思是，我无法想象在那么年轻的时候经历这些有多么艰难。
If the show provided comfort, it's amazing.
如果这部剧能提供慰藉，那真是太棒了。
It's amazing that seems like she's almost the age now that her mother was, if I was tracking that correctly.
太惊人了，如果我没记错的话，她现在几乎和她母亲当年去世时的年龄一样大。
So for the show to have meant that to her, and now she's an adult and at that age, and like that it's still part of her life, Thank you so much today.
所以，这部剧对她曾有这样的意义，而现在她长大了，到了那个年纪，它仍然是她生活的一部分，今天非常感谢你。
That is very much was our greatest hope in making this show that it would reach somebody like you Ash and at the moment you needed it.
这正是我们制作这部剧时最大的期望，希望它能触动像你这样的人，阿什，就在你最需要它的时候。
Thank you for letting us know that.
谢谢你让我们知道这一切。
I mean, that is the greatest gift just to know that.
我的意思是，知道这些就是最棒的礼物。
And if anyone has other stories they'd like to share about what how I met your mother means to them or something funny or, you know, it can be anything, please go to how we meet your mother.com, go to contact and write us a note, drop us a voice note.
如果任何人还有其他故事想要分享，关于《老爸老妈浪漫史》对他们意味着什么，或者什么有趣的事，你知道的，什么都可以，请访问 howwemetyourmother.com，点击联系我们并给我们写张便条，或者留下语音留言。
we're always happy to hear from people, because that's why we're doing this show.
我们总是很高兴听到大家的分享，因为这就是我们做这个节目的原因。
And today, speaking of the show, we are talking about, I would call this a season one classic, nothing good happens after two a.m.
今天，说到这部剧，我们要谈论的是，我称之为第一季的经典剧集——《凌晨两点后没有好事发生》。
I would also say, Jordana, obviously my wife, she had never seen the show, but when I said it's called nothing good happens after two a.m.
我还要说的是，乔丹娜，显然我的妻子，她以前从未看过这部剧，但当我告诉她剧名叫《凌晨两点后没有好事发生》时，
She says, I know that phrase, like I think it's one of those phrases.
她说：“我知道这个短语”，就好像我觉得这是那种广为人知的短语一样。
That's happening now.
现在它正在发生。
Yeah, that's how things are getting out there and boomeranging back at us and people are like, That's a phrase, and it's like, actually, I think it's, because of our stuff.
对，这就是事情传播开来又回流到我们身上，人们会说：“这是一个短语啊”，而事实是，我认为这其实是因为我们的剧。
We might have invented that phrase.
我们可能发明了这个短语。
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, Courtney Kang's mother, Courtney Kang, one of our writers' mother would say that to Courtney Kang and that it made it on how much a mother.
是的，考特尼·康的母亲——考特尼·康是我们的一位编剧——她的母亲经常对考特尼·康说这句话，后来它就出现在了《老爸老妈浪漫史》里。
So maybe that was a phrase that Courtney Kang's mother was about not going back.
所以也许那曾是考特尼·康的母亲关于不要晚归的一句口头禅。
At least in the Kang household.
至少在姜家是这样的。
At least in the Kang household, it was a famous saying.
至少在姜家，这是一句名言。
Yeah, but it does feel like now it's one of those things maybe it's sticky because you don't have to live long live long to have proven the truth of it.
是的，不过现在感觉这就像那种让人印象深刻的话，因为你不用活太久就能证明它是对的。
You know what I'm saying?
你知道我的意思吗？
Yes, like we've all had that thing at like 2.30 or 3, and you're like, why am I here?
对，就像我们都在两点半或三点的时候经历过那种时刻，你会想，我为什么会在这里？
This is where bad things happen.
这就是坏事发生的地方。
This is the hour where dark things happen.
这是黑暗之事发生的时刻。
The decisions aren't getting better from here on out.
从现在开始，情况不会变得更好了。
There's no upward trend at this point.
此时没有任何上升的趋势。
Yeah, and I love that feeling in this episode, that feeling of immediate ominousness.
对，我很喜欢这一集里的那种感觉，那种即将来临的不祥预感。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Future Ted telling his kids this law of physics, love the universe, nothing good happens after 2am, and the whole episode, you know immediately it's going to go bad.
未来的泰德告诉他的孩子们这条物理定律，爱的宇宙，凌晨两点之后没有好事发生，整集节目里，你立刻就知道事情要搞砸了。
It's like a disaster movie.
这就像一部灾难片。
Like you know there's going to be a tornado, there's going to be an earthquake, like something bad is going to happen and it does, and I sort of love that about this one.
就像你知道会有一场龙卷风，会有一场地震，某种不好的事情即将发生，结果确实发生了，我挺喜欢这一集这一点。
Remember I told you that thing of if you were a character in a movie, what would people be screaming at you to do or not do?
还记得我跟你说过那个问题吗，如果你是电影里的角色，大家会尖叫着让你做什么或不做什么？
Yes.
记得。
And you have this chorus, especially Marshall and Lily, Barney seems a little more encouraging, they're like, they know this is a bad idea.
然后你就会听到一阵劝阻声，特别是马歇尔和莉莉，巴尼看起来稍微更鼓励一点，他们就觉得，他们知道这是个坏主意。
Please don't go over there.
求求你别去那边。
Um, so let's just, let's just set the scene, set some context for this episode.
嗯，那我们，我们来设定一下场景，为这一集做些背景铺垫。
Alec, when did this episode air?
亚历克，这一集是什么时候播出的？
It's aired on April 10th, 2006.
它于2006年4月10日播出。
April 10th, 2006.
2006年4月10日。
Okay.
好的。
And, uh, Craig, give us the, uh, kind of, uh, synopsis of, and, and start us at the end of, uh, life among the gorillas, because that's really where this episode gets, uh, teed up and kicked off.
然后，呃，克雷格，给我们做个，呃，大致的剧情概述，从《猩球生活》的结尾开始讲起，因为这正是本集的引子和开端。
Can I just note that the episode before before this came out on March 20th.
我能提一下吗，这一集之前的那集是3月20日播出的。
So you had 20 days.
所以你们隔了20天。
It was a big gap, which is funny because when I watched this last night with my wife and like, I said, we never did those previously things.
这是一个很大的间隔，这很有趣，因为昨晚我和妻子看这一集时，我说，我们以前从不做那些“前情提要”的事。
Do you know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
The previously is baked into the episode on this one.
这一集里直接内置了“前情提要”。
So basically the narrative is like, here's what happened or, you know, I just previously on how much of other basically.
所以基本上叙事就像是，这里发生了什么，或者，你知道的，我只是回顾一下之前大概的内容。
And it was because of that, I said to her, I think there was probably several weeks of ways from that one Monday to the next and it was a cliffhanger.
正因如此，我对她说，从那个星期一到下一个星期一之间可能隔了好几个星期，而且那是个悬念。
But isn't it funny, like in 2006, we somewhat still had attention spans and collective cultural memory that we do not have now.
但不是很搞笑吗，在2006年，我们多少还有点注意力和集体文化记忆，而现在我们没有了。
Like it's been so eroded at this point.
就像现在已经被侵蚀得差不多了。
Like if it's on the next day, you have to be like previously.
就像如果是第二天播的，你也得来一句“前情提要”。
Here's what happened.
以下是发生的事情。
Yeah, they remind you.
对，他们会提醒你。
I know you've forgotten, yeah.
我知道你已经忘了，对。
So yeah, that was funny to see that.
所以，看到这个挺搞笑的。
I think it's maybe the only time in the series we kind of quite baked it in that over me.
我想这可能是该剧中唯一一次我们把它内置得这么明显。
Like you need a reminder audience of what happened.
就像你需要提醒观众发生了什么一样。
But the cliffhanger at the end of life among the gorillas is that Ted is waiting late at night to get a call from Victoria who's in Germany on many hours ahead of him the next day.
但《猩球生活》结尾的悬念是，泰德在深夜等待维多利亚的电话，维多利亚在德国，比他早好几个小时。
And the film rings and it's not Victoria who he thinks is calling him to break up with him.
电话响了，打来的不是维多利亚——他以为维多利亚打电话是要跟他分手。
It is in fact Robin who is inviting him over at about two in the morning.
实际上是罗宾，她在凌晨两点左右邀请他过去。
And the episode takes off from there.
这一集就从这里开始了。
It's the dilemma of what do you do?
这就是两难境地：你该怎么办？
What do you do with this?
你该怎么处理这个？
You think you're breaking up with your Rhonda's relationship and the girl you're kind of secretly you're not so secretly in love with calls you over two in the morning.
你以为你正处在维多利亚这段稳定的关系中，而那个你暗恋、甚至不是那么暗恋的女孩在凌晨两点叫你过去。
And that is this episode.
这就是这一集的内容。
Yeah.
对。
What, these phones that they had, did they have caller ID, like no one- I kept wondering that.
什么，他们用的这些手机，有来电显示吗，好像没人——我一直在想这个。
No one knows who's calling.
没人知道是谁打来的。
Everyone just answers the phone like it's like a- Totally.
大家接电话都觉得——完全同意。
A landline, you know?
就那种座机，你知道吗？
Yeah, and if I did- it's a crucial plot point in this, is that Robin would answer the phone not seeing that it was Ted's phone lighting up with Victoria's name because it's not a smartphone, it's 2006, it's a flip phone.
对，如果我——这里面有个关键剧情，就是罗宾接电话时没看到泰德的手机上亮着维多利亚的名字，因为那不是智能手机，那是2006年，那是翻盖手机。
I think you just opened the phone and answered it.
我觉得你就是把手机翻开然后接了。
some point flip phones or you could see, right?
翻盖手机到某个时候，或者你能看见，对吧？
At some point, I'm looking at you, like, you remember this, I don't know why you're the expert in this, but I think there was a, there's a little glass thing on the front that you could see, but this is also back in the day when people were answering phone calls, like no one's doing that now.
说到某个时候，我看着你，就好像，你还记得这个，我不知道为什么你成了这方面的专家，但我觉得前面好像有个小玻璃窗能看到来电，不过这也是以前人们还会接电话的年代，现在没人这么干了。
Like no one's, it's like, it's like an etiquette breach to call people, it's like, what are you doing?
就像没人会，这就好比，这简直是社交礼仪上的冒犯，给别人打电话，就像，你在干嘛？
It's an incredible invasion of privacy to call someone with a texting person.
在有短信的时代给别人打电话，简直是对隐私的极度侵犯。
people who just call on each other and not know any of the fucks cuts of the wild west.
那些动不动就给别人打电话、完全不管不顾的人，就像蛮荒西部一样。
Well, that's the focus crucial plot points in this are related to that.
好吧，这里的核心关键剧情就跟这有关。
And it does feel like a ticket dated, but you need to make the buy.
这听起来确实有点过时，但你得接受设定。
My favorite thing about that.
我对那集最喜欢的一点。
Here's my two favorite things about this episode.
关于这一集，我最喜欢的两点是这样的。
And the first one will sound like I'm criticizing.
第一点听起来可能像是在批评。
But we've Carter and I wrote this one, by the way, the brilliant Carter Bay is.
顺便说一句，这集是我和卡特写的，才华横溢的卡特·贝斯。
I feel like Carter did excellent excellent work on this one.
我觉得卡特在这集里写得太棒了、太出色了。
I feel like maybe he started this one off and then I kind of counter or punched it a bit, really brilliant writing.
我觉得可能是他开了个头，然后我进行了一些补充和完善，真的是绝妙的剧本。
I love how it's kind of all in largely in real time.
我特别喜欢它基本上全是以实时的方式展开。
It has that really urgent feeling of like, it's all happening late at night.
那种感觉非常紧迫，就像所有事情都发生在深夜。
It feels late at night.
感觉就像是深夜。
It feels like you're dizzy and drunk on the lateness of the night and the ominousness of what may happen.
感觉就像你因为夜色已深而有些头晕目眩、微醺，还带着一种可能发生什么的厄运感。
I really like that vibe.
我真的很喜欢那种氛围。
My first comment on that episode is, I love how few jokes there are in it.
我对这一集的第一点评论是，我喜欢里面几乎没什么笑话。
Yeah.
对。
That's a really weird compliment.
这真的是一个很奇怪的夸奖。
I mean it as a compliment because it is daringly and defiantly un-jokey, and I really like that.
我是当成夸奖说的，因为它极其大胆、极其叛逆地不玩笑梗，我真的很喜欢这一点。
I really like it because it is a play this one.
我真的很喜欢，因为这一集就像是一部戏剧。
This is a theater, you're acting in this episode, Josh, is A, superb and B, theater acting.
这是一部话剧，乔什，你在这集里的表演，A，棒极了，B，很有舞台剧表演的感觉。
I mean that in the best possible way.
我是用最好的方式来形容这一点。
You are acting a drama in this episode in the best way.
你在这集里以最好的方式在演一出正剧。
Well, it's also like, it's theatrical in like almost a classic sense.
嗯，而且它在某种经典意义上也具有戏剧性。
It's like, there's a ghost in this episode.
就好像，这集里有一个鬼魂。
It's like- That's my thing too, you stole my thing too.
就像——这也是我想说的，你把我的话抢先了。
My thing too, my second comment is, it's a fucking ghost story.
我也是这个意思，我的第二个评论是，这他妈就是一个鬼故事。
Yeah.
对。
This episode's so great because it's a ghost story.
这一集太棒了，因为它是个鬼故事。
How great is Ashley at playing that ghost version of Victoria, this kind of Victoria, the kind of different.
阿什莉把那个维多利亚的鬼魂版本演得有多棒，那种维多利亚，那种与众不同的感觉。
I was blown away by how great the two of you were in those scenes, truly great.
你们俩在那些场景里的表现让我大为震撼，真的是太棒了。
It's Hamlet, it's Our Town.
这就是《哈姆雷特》，这就是《我们的小镇》。
We're tapping into the theatricality of the ghost character.
我们正在挖掘鬼魂角色的戏剧张力。
The whole episode is the ghost.
整集节目本身就是那个鬼魂。
What episode is this, 18?
这是第几集，第18集？
18, that's 22.
18集，那是第22集。
So you're 18 episodes in and you've established a kind of rapport with the audience.
所以拍到第18集时，你们已经和观众建立了一种默契。
characters are so sharply etched and defined at this point.
此时此刻，角色已经被刻画得非常鲜明、定义明确了。
The the the on again off the the love story or almost love story of Ted and Robin is so firmly established.
泰德和罗宾分分合合的爱情故事，或者说几乎算得上爱情的故事，已经非常稳固了。
Yeah.
对。
And you I think you guys have done a masterful job of turning Robin's affections toward Ted very gradually very gradually to the point where she kind of can't you know and he's it's just such a great thing especially for like a love avoidant, like Robin, she can't, because she can't have Ted, her, her affections get amplified so much, right?
而且我觉得你们做了一件非常高明的事，就是非常缓慢地、极其循序渐进地将罗宾对泰德的情感引导出来，直到她某种程度上无法抗拒——你知道的——而且对像罗宾这样一个有些爱情回避倾向的人来说，这真的是太棒了，因为她无法拥有泰德，她的情感反而被放大了那么多，对吧？
But you've really narratively just pulled back the bow.
但你们在叙事上真的就像是把弓拉满了。
It's so taught at the end of guerrillas.
到《游击战》结尾时那种张力太紧绷了。
So when you let it fly in this episode, it doesn't need jokes because it's also, the stakes are quite high.
所以当你在这一集里让它释放出来时，根本不需要笑话，因为不仅如此，赌注也非常高。
The stakes are higher in this episode, I would argue than any other episode in the first season.
我认为这一集的赌注比第一季中的任何其他集都要高。
I think one of the things that Marshall and Lily are scared about is they realize that this friend group is pretty special they like Robin they like having Robin around yes they've really grown accustomed to having her around and Ted and Robin are threatening this this ecosystem they're threatening yes the kind of petri dish they're all living in which is interesting too because like Marshall and Lily kind of go from wanting Ted and Robin to get together to not wanting that in this episode because it will be built on a lie and the foundation of of this relationship being built on kind of this crime that Lily calls it.
我认为马歇尔和莉莉害怕的一点是，他们意识到这个朋友圈非常特别，他们喜欢罗宾，喜欢罗宾在身边，是的，他们已经习惯了有她陪伴的日子，而泰德和罗宾正在威胁这个生态系统，是的，他们正在威胁所有人赖以生存的那个培养皿，这也很有趣，因为马歇尔和莉莉在这个过程中，从一开始希望泰德和罗宾在一起，变成了在这集里不希望他们在一起，因为这段关系将建立在一个谎言之上，而且这段关系的基石是建立在莉莉所说的这种“罪行”之上的。
She's like, don't start it this way, right?
她说，别以这种方式开始，对吧？
If you guys are going to become that couple that we sit on that front porch with in the future and grow old with and we'll all be couple best friends forever, it can't be built on like this really messy moment after that two in the morning.
如果你们以后要成为那种能和我们一起坐在前廊上、一起变老、永远是最好朋友的伴侣，那它就不能建立在凌晨两点发生的那种非常混乱的时刻之上。
And I wrote you this little day to send you in New York City.
我为你写了这首小诗，送给纽约市的你。
will be right back and now back to the show.
我们马上回来，现在回到节目中。
Did you by any chance, I just read this yesterday and I know I referenced an Atlantic article in the last episode, you're gonna know what my reading habits are.
你有没有——我昨天刚读到这个，我知道我在上一集里提到了《大西洋月刊》的一篇文章，你大概知道我的阅读习惯。
But there's an article in the Atlantic.
但《大西洋月刊》上有一篇文章。
Aren't they one of our sponsors?
他们不是我们的赞助商之一吗？
No way, that's me on these.
不可能，这是我的私房话。
Sorry, I confused them as the Atlantic with me on these.
抱歉，我把它和“我的私房话”搞混了。
But the Atlantic, they have an article about how the Simpsons is essentially a moral show.
不过《大西洋月刊》上有一篇文章，讲的是为什么《辛普森一家》本质上是一部具有道德内涵的剧集。
Like it's moral center is very strong.
就像它的道德核心非常强大一样。
I totally agree.
我完全同意。
Back in the day remember when bush one said we need we need a culture much more like the Waltons than the Simpsons And it was considered like because because Bart was like disrespecting and he was an underachiever We we thought it was leading to moral collapse not we but you know what I mean like this kind of so But they said like the Simpsons is essentially like if you if you really track it It's got like a really strong moral center And I would argue that how I met your mother has a really strong moral center in that You know, Lilly also often functions as the moral conscience of the show.
过去老布什不是说过吗，我们需要一种更像《沃尔顿家族》而不是《辛普森一家》的文化，当时这被认为是因为巴特很不尊重人，而且是个表现不佳的学生，我们当时以为这会导致道德崩溃——不是我们，但你知道我的意思——这种观点认为……但文章说，其实《辛普森一家》本质上，如果你深入去追踪它的话，它有着非常强大的道德核心。而我想说的是，《老爸老妈浪漫史》也有一个非常强大的道德核心，因为莉莉也经常扮演剧中的道德良知。
Yeah, right.
对，没错。
She's, she's often the one saying like, you can't do this, like, this is wrong, like, this is going to, but I, but I agree that there, but I, I wonder, was that something you guys ever discussed in the, or is that just an outgrowth of you and Carter being generally like good people, like, you know what I'm saying, or, or is that something TV has to be moral?
她经常是那个说“你不能这么做”、“这不对”、“这会导致……”的人，不过我赞同，但我很好奇，这是你们当时讨论过的事情，还是说这只是你和卡特本身就是好人的一种自然流露，你知道我的意思吗？还是说电视剧本来就必须得有道德感？
Do you know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
Yeah, I do, I do, I think we wanted, I mean, thank you for that, that's very nice.
对，我明白，我明白，我觉得我们希望——谢谢你的夸奖，这太好了。
And yeah, I think we're people, here's the thing, here's what I think we're aiming at, to know that to show out a moral core, but to still show these characters doing the wrong thing sometimes.
是的，我觉得我们这些人，这就是我们的目标：既要展现出剧集的道德核心，同时又要展现这些角色有时也会做错事。
Especially Ted, who is so winning and charming and he's so open-hearted and wants, but he's still a guy, he's still a guy who has these feelings for this beautiful woman who has called him in the morning.
特别是泰德，他那么讨人喜欢、那么有魅力，内心那么坦荡、充满渴望，但他终究是个普通人，他依然会对这个在凌晨给他打电话的美丽女人产生这种情感。
So I'd say like, yes, a moral center from Future Ted telling, from moment one, even from the ending of the previous episode, Future Ted's kind of saying buckle up, your old man fucked up here a little bit.
所以我可以说，是的，未来的泰德从一开始就在讲述时设立了一个道德核心，甚至从上一集的结尾开始，未来的泰德就在某种程度上提醒大家系好安全带，你们的老爸在这里搞砸了一点。
Yeah.
对。
Well, it just occurred to me the very convention of him telling his kids, like when we tell our kids stories, we're trying to impose, we're trying to impart some moral lesson.
嗯，我突然想到，他给孩子们讲故事这个设定本身——就像我们给我们自己的孩子讲故事时，我们总是试图强加某种道德教训，试图传达某种道德课程。
That's the moral part.
这就是道德的部分。
That's the moral part is kind of Future Ted looking back going like, this wasn't me at my best.
道德的部分其实就是未来的泰德回首往事时说：那并不是我最好的状态。
If I can spare you this in your life, listen to your old man right now.
如果我能让你们在生活中免于这种错误，现在就听听你们老爸的劝吧。
Yes, because I still don't feel good about this.
是的，因为直到现在我对这件事还是觉得心里很不舒服。
These things that you tell yourself are okay at two in the morning, you may not feel that way even 25 years hence, yeah.
那些你在凌晨两点说服自己觉得没问题的事情，甚至在25年之后，你可能都不会这么觉得了，对。
You know, it occurs to me also, Ted has a break glass in case of emergency catchphrase that seems to grant him permission to do whatever he wants and it's, but it's Robin.
你知道吗，我还想到，泰德有一个“遇紧急情况打破玻璃”式的口头禅，这似乎赋予了他做任何想做的事的权利，而且每次都是为了罗宾。
Like, whenever he says it's Robin.
就像，每当他说出口的时候，都是为了罗宾。
Yeah, you murdered a man, but for Rob, I did it.
对，你谋杀了一个人，但为了罗宾，我这么做了。
But it was a hitchhiker, Ted, it had nothing to do with Robin.
但那是个搭便车的人，泰德，这跟罗宾一点关系都没有。
You just hit a guy.
你只是撞了一个人。
But Robin, no, it's really true.
但为了罗宾——不，这真的太真实了。
Now, when you got this script, did you feel like his, like, Ted is all of a sudden in this crime movie at two in the morning, in this episode?
话说当年你拿到这个剧本时，有没有觉得，比如泰德——泰德突然在这一集里卷入了一场凌晨两点的犯罪电影中？
Like, this is like a different Ted, a different tone.
就像，这是一个不同的泰德，一种不同的基调。
What did you think when you read this one, were you at all like, ooh, this is messy for Ted?
你读到这一集时是怎么想的？你有没有觉得“哦，这对泰德来说太乱了”？
Are we like, who cool?
还是觉得“哇，太酷了”？
This is juicy for Ted.
这对于泰德来说非常有张力。
This is, I get to do some good acting here.
这能让我好好发挥一下演技。
Oh no, no, I was thinking for as an actor, you're like, this is gold.
哦不不，我当时作为演员的想法是，这简直是块金子。
I'm never, I have a long running argument with my dad and I don't know if I've shared about this, but it's worth sharing.
我和我爸有一个长期争论的话题，我不知道我有没有分享过，但非常值得一说。
I've had, I mean, there's been a decades long argument with my dad.
我跟我爸有过长达几十年的争论。
My dad watches things and he's a big consumer of TV.
我爸经常看各种东西，而且是个电视迷。
He loves TV, but he also watches everything through this like pretty strict moral lens where he'll finish like 75% of the things he finishes you up.
他很喜欢看电视，但他看什么东西都带着一种非常严苛的道德标准，比如他看完的剧里大约有百分之七十五……
Why did they screw up their lives so bad?
为什么他们要把生活搞得这么一团糟？
Why do people make these choices that screw up their lives so bad?
为什么人们会做出把生活搞得这么一团糟的选择？
And I always say, so you could have a TV show to watch.
我总是说，这样你们才有电视剧可看啊。
That's not super fucking boring.
这总不会他妈的无聊透顶吧。
Yeah.
对啊。
I said, do you want to watch people make the right decisions all the time?
我说，难道你们想看人们时时刻刻都做出正确决定吗？
Like there's no story.
那就完全没有故事了。
Like we tell stories about fatal flaws, about hubris, about this is when I really stepped in it.
比如我们讲的故事都是关于致命的缺陷、傲慢、以及“我当时真是昏了头”这种时刻。
We like to watch people get tangled enough so we can watch them untangle.
我们喜欢看人们陷入纠葛，这样我们就能看他们如何解开纠葛。
That story is conflict, right?
这种故事就是冲突，对吧？
That is it.
就是这样。
Yeah.
对啊。
So when I, as an actor, you're looking for, oh, wow, this puts me in this ties this character and not.
所以当我作为演员，你会寻找，哦，哇，这让我进入了……这把这个角色和……
It's like, this is going to be really fun to play because he's to play, you know, two different things that are pulling you in two totally different directions.
就好像，这演起来会非常有趣，因为他要同时展现，你知道的，两种把你往完全相反方向拉扯的东西。
I mean, it's really a war with his, uh, it's his ego and his, and his super ego and his id kind of hashing it out.
我是说，这其实是一场战争，他的……这是他的自我、超我以及本我在进行一番搏斗。
You know, he's, he's really at war with himself and the specter or the ghost of Victoria is just his own conscience spinning this, uh, apparition to be in front of him to play the other side out.
你知道的，他真的是在与自己交战，而维多利亚的幻影或鬼魂，不过是他自己的良心在编造出这么一个幻象，出现在他面前来扮演内心的另一面。
Yeah.
对啊。
It's almost future him and two, Victoria's future him and Lily's kind of future him and there's like three future tabs kind of in his episode being like put on the brakes buddy and he can't quite do it.
这几乎可以说是未来的他与维多利亚，未来的他与莉莉，有点像未来的他，他的脑海里有三个未来的网页标签在这一集中跳出来说：“踩刹车吧，老兄，”但他却完全做不到。
He tries.
他试过了。
He really does try at a certain moment to do it any episode, which I also really liked, right and that one that right before they can, he really tries to say goodbye, I love that.
他在某一刻真的是竭力想这么做，在某一集里，我也真的很喜欢这一点，对吧，就在那之前，他真的很努力地想说再见，我太喜欢那个了。
I love that moment where you try to pull out of the nose dive.
我太喜欢你试图从飞机俯冲的状态中拉回来的那一刻了。
But it's also so true, there's that, okay, I should go and then there's the hug, which doesn't break.
但这也是那么真实，有那种“好吧，我该走了”，然后是那个没有放开的拥抱。
And then there's like, are we trying to pull out of the hug?
然后就像是，我们在试图从拥抱中退出来吗？
Oh no, our cheek are brushing against each other.
噢不，我们的脸颊在互相擦过。
I guess I'll go, oh no, we're kissing.
我想我该走了，噢不，我们在接吻。
Like, there was something so great about the choreography, it was so, you know, so recognizable.
就像，那段编排有种绝妙之处，它是那么的……你知道的，那么容易引发共鸣。
What disgusting thing did she whisper in your air right before that take?
在拍摄那个镜头之前，她在你耳边低语了什么恶心的东西？
I don't know if Coby said she always did it.
我不知道，柯比说她一直都这么做。
Yeah, I don't think we were at that because I think that started when they started doing it.
对，我觉得我们当时还没到那个地步，因为我觉得那是他们开始这么做之后才有的。
When they were in bed and had the couple thing go in.
当他们躺在床上，有了那种情侣间的互动时。
Maybe even Coby was like, I don't know him well enough to drop the scat humor I'm going to drop later.
也许连柯比当时都觉得，我对他的了解还不够深，不足以开我后来要开的那些重口味玩笑。
You built to that.
你是逐渐培养到那种程度的。
You built to that, which makes sense.
你是慢慢铺垫到那里的，这很合理。
Yeah, exactly.
对，确实如此。
Now, I really felt that electricity and your performance here, her too.
真的，我能从你的表演中感受到那种电光石火般的张力，她也是。
I mean, like too, you've been like, you're following Ted out there from Manhattan to Brooklyn.
我是说，还有……你就像是在一路尾随泰德，从曼哈顿到布鲁克林。
It's like you're witnessing, there's this real feeling of like, he's in trouble, he's transressing.
就好像你在见证，有一种强烈的真实感：他惹麻烦了，他在越轨。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
You've got a bag full of produce.
你手里还提着一袋农产品。
Yeah, the juicing is so funny.
对，榨汁那段太搞笑了。
But you know that, I think Jordana kind of responded when he said park slope and pointed out like the Upper West Side to Park Slope is a real journey.
但你知道的，我觉得乔丹娜当时那种反应很到位，当他说出公园坡（Park Slope）并指出从上西区到公园坡可是一段真正的长途跋涉时。
It is.
确实是。
It's not 15 minutes.
根本不是15分钟。
It's got a lot of time to think about it.
那有大把的时间让人胡思乱想。
It's a lot, even late at night, that's still gonna be like, is that it like a 40 minute?
时间可长了，哪怕是在深夜，那也得要……得要40分钟吧？
I'd say solid 35, 40 minutes.
我觉得稳稳当当得35、40分钟。
Yeah, it's a 35, 40 minute ride.
对，得坐35、40分钟的车。
So he has a lot of time to fantasize.
所以他有足够的时间进行各种幻想。
And then he has to switch cabs because the cab driver is drinking.
然后他还得换出租车，因为那个出租车司机在喝酒。
But I felt the electricity in your performance.
但我确实感受到了你表演中的火花。
I could tell like, you were into it.
我能看得出来，你很投入。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
You knew this was like, this was a juicy one.
你知道这很带劲，这是一个很有发挥空间的角色。
And I thought that would be your answer that you'd be like, no, I saw this was juicy.
我还以为你会回答说，不，我看出这很有发挥空间了呢。
It was almost like, um, it was almost like as a theater actor, which at that time, I still considered myself mostly a theater actor.
感觉就像是，嗯……感觉作为一个话剧演员——当时我还主要把自己当成一个话剧演员。
That was where most of my hours as an actor were on stage, not in front of the camera.
我作为演员的大部分时间都是在舞台上度过的，而不是在摄像机前。
Yeah.
对。
But there was something so, and I think it's significant that, you know, Carter was late to Wesleyan, right?
但有些东西非常重要，而且我认为卡特进卫斯理大学比较晚，这很有意义，对吧？
Cause he had won like the young playwriting conference and he had an off-Broadway production of a play in New York City when he was 17 or 18, right?
因为他曾赢得过青年剧本创作会议的奖项，而且他在17或18岁时，在纽约市就有一部外百老汇制作的戏剧上演了，对吧？
It's true.
确实如此。
And there was always something, and maybe that's why I got the role, or some sort of, I always felt like you're guys writing, this one in particular really could have been a play.
而且总有一种感觉——也许这就是我得到这个角色的原因，或者某种类似的直觉——我一直觉得你们俩写的剧本，尤其是这一集，真的可以被改编成一出舞台剧。
And I approached it, I think, as a play, you know?
我想我是把它当成一出舞台剧来对待的，你知道吗？
This scene in the bathroom with Victoria and Ted felt the most kind of like a scene in a play.
维多利亚和泰德在浴室里的这场戏，最让人觉得像是一出舞台剧里的场景。
Yes.
没错。
确实如此。
And it's true, you guys didn't, you didn't have a, I mean, you cut back to Marshall and Lillian Barney, which I now realize if we're really following this through, they're the Greek chorus, right?
而且真的，你们没有……你们没有把镜头……我是说，镜头切回了马修、莉莉和巴尼，我后来意识到，如果我们顺着这个思路看下去，他们就是希腊歌队，对吧？
Like they're the, they don't really have a story going.
就像他们是……他们其实并没有什么故事线在推进。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
They're really there for 10 minutes.
他们真的就出现10分钟。
I mean, Korean Elvis.
我是说，韩国猫王。
Korean Elvis is amazing.
韩国猫王太绝了。
But like they, they really are there.
但他们……他们确实就在那里。
It's all, everybody's on one track, basically, right?
基本上所有人都聚焦在同一条主线上，对吧？
They're, it's, it is like theater and that like, there's no B story.
他们……这真的很像戏剧，因为没有副线剧情（B故事）。
Carter always talks about that.
卡特总是谈论这一点。
He's, he was always a great voice of like, Let's not be slavish to B stories and C stories.
他一直是个很好的声音，主张：我们不要盲目地去迎合副线剧情（B故事）和支线剧情（C故事）。
Let's, some episodes are the A story and everything is about, everyone's weighing in on that.
有些剧集就是主线（A故事），一切都围绕着它展开，所有人都在对这件事发表看法。
Everyone's, especially in these ones that take place in kind of in real time.
每个人都在讨论，尤其是在这些几乎是实时发生的剧集里。
And so much, so many great hymnium episodes are like that.
许多优秀的《老爸老妈浪漫史》剧集都是这样的。
Carter was a great, he was a religious devotee to a, let's make it one thing.
卡特是个狂热的信奉者，坚信“让我们只专注讲好一件事”。
I mean, not every episode, is that not every great hymnium episode?
我是说，是不是每一集都这样？难道不是每一集精彩的《老爸老妈浪漫史》都这样吗？
Is that it's good to mix it up?
偶尔换换口味也挺好的吧？
But to be able to do that speed is great.
但能把那种节奏把握好真的很棒。
It's two things.
这是两码事。
one, when you're telling a story to your kids, it's like, it is kind of strange when you go, meanwhile, over here, there was this unrelated thing was happening, which doesn't actually have that much bearing.
第一，当你给孩子们讲故事时，如果你突然说：“与此同时，在另一边，发生了另一件毫不相干的事，其实跟主线没多大关系”，这听起来会有点奇怪。
But we talked about this earlier, but like, when there's an event, like, nothing good happens after 2am, no other thing is going to be a missable.
但我们之前也讨论过，当发生某种事情时，比如“午夜两点之后不会发生什么好事”，没有什么事是不可错过的。
It's the thing.
就是这件事本身。
就是它。
Yeah.
对。
I love how the episodes, I love going back to to Robin's day, like showing how she got in this pretty fragile, vulnerable, somewhat needy place where she was like, I need this guy to come over right now.
我喜欢这些剧集的一点是，我喜欢回溯到罗宾的那一天，展示她是如何陷入那种相当脆弱、无助、甚至有点需要陪伴的境地，以至于她说出：“我需要这个家伙立刻赶过来。”
Yeah, I really liked that.
对，我真的很喜欢那个。
Here's 20 hours earlier.
镜头一转：20个小时前。
And like, yeah, it felt very cinematic that moment.
而且，是的，那一刻感觉非常有电影感。
It feels more like a play or a movie this episode than a second episode, which I love.
比起情景喜剧的常规剧集，这一集感觉更像是一部戏剧或电影，我太喜欢了。
And I love meaning Sandy Rivers, by the way, just we got to give a shout out to Alexis Denisov.
另外我指的是桑迪·里弗斯，顺便说一句，我们得向阿历克谢·杰尼索夫致敬。
Yeah.
对。
Unbelievable introduction to Sandy Rivers.
桑迪·里弗斯的出场简直不可思议。
But there was, you guys didn't go to this well all that often, but every time you did, I thought it was hilarious, which is her kindergarten class.
不过，你们并不经常使用这种套路，但每次你们用的时候，我都觉得太滑稽了，也就是她的幼儿园班级。
Yes.
是的。
So funny.
太好笑了。
Always funny.
总是那么好笑。
Are you a lesbian?
你是女同性恋吗？
So funny.
太好笑了。
Oh my God.
噢，天哪。
And then also Barney, like, you know, just being like, we're not going to talk about my job.
然后还有巴尼，你知道的，就好像在说，我们不谈论我的工作。
We're going to do magic.
我们要变魔术。
And he crushes.
而且他表现超棒。
Yeah.
对。
Absolutely.
绝对是的。
I remember just sit there like dying inside about her own identity watching him kill in front of these kids.
我记得自己就坐在那里，看着他在这些孩子面前大获成功，内心却在为她自己的身份认同感到煎熬。
Yeah, her having this horrible soul-searching day, including being hit on by Alison Haddigan's husband, not in real life, but the character he played, Alexis Enesoff, who is the nicest dude in the world, and lean into the playing, this smarmy asshole character so hard, because he's the nicest guy in the world, and knew he could do this.
是的，她经历了这糟糕透顶、进行灵魂拷问的一天，包括被艾莉森·哈迪根（Alison Haddigan）的丈夫搭讪——当然不是在现实生活中，而是他扮演的角色阿历克西斯·埃内索夫（Alexis Enesoff），他是世界上最好的人，却极力去扮演这样一个油腔滑调的混蛋角色，因为他是世界上最好的人，而且知道自己能胜任。
Also, it should be noted, that's his real hair.
另外，需要说明的是，那是他真正的头发。
Yeah, that's a wonderful- That's his real hair, just his hair.
对，那是一个非常——那是他真正的头发，就是他自己的头发。
His hair- His hair- Totally his castard out.
他的头发——他的头发——完全是他天生这样的。
So not who he is in real life, but he really enjoyed it.
所以这根本不是他在现实生活中的样子，但他真的很享受。
Do you know what was funny when I was watching Alexis, who I just, it's like I hadn't forgotten how good he is, but there's so much pleasure in watching.
你知道当我看到阿历克西斯时有什么好笑的吗？我只是，就好像我没有忘记他有多优秀，但是看他表演本身就是一种巨大的享受。
Yeah, he has, he does this weird thing, which Neil does a lot, which is like, it's an incredibly kind of broad character at once, but it's also subtle.
对，他有一种，他有一种奇怪的特质，尼尔身上也有很多，那就是它同时既是一种非常宽泛的角色，但又很微妙。
He's doing something very subtle.
他在做一些非常微妙的事情。
He's always subtle too, it's really true.
他一直都很微妙，真的确实如此。
But the way he was just kind of listening to her, like on the phone, and the way he was kind of, The nonchalance, which he, he, he suggests that they should have sex with each other.
但他那种倾听她的方式，比如在电话里，还有他那种漫不经心，他暗示他们应该发生性关系。
I love so much, how he said, having sex is fun.
我太喜欢他说“做爱很有趣”的那种方式了。
Having sex is fun.
做爱很有趣。
So funny.
太好笑了。
So good.
太棒了。
Allison always says to him, it's sort of like a compliment to both his looks and his acting.
艾莉森总是对他说，这既是对他外表的一种赞美，也是对他演技的一种赞美。
She's like, he's a leading man, you know, he's a character actor, trapped in a leading man body.
她说，他是一个男主角，你知道的，是一个被困在男主角身体里的性格演员。
Like he's so, he's a good looking dude, but so capable of leaning into that character, he's stuffed to, while maintaining kind of a groundedness, he's a, I am a huge fan of the show, Angel, which he was brilliant on Alexis was, and it was so we were thrilled to get him on the show.
就像他非常，他是个长相不错的家伙，但却能如此游刃有余地诠释那个角色，在保持一种脚踏实地的感觉的同时，把角色塑造得淋漓尽致。我是剧集《天使》的超级粉丝，他在里面的表现极其出色，而阿历克西斯就是其中之一，所以我们能请他来参演这部剧，大家都兴奋不已。
I also, I remember that Alexis, and he did a bunch of episodes as Sandy Rivers, but he never didn't kill.
我还记得，阿历克西斯——他作为桑迪·里弗斯（Sandy Rivers）演了好几集，但他每一次出场都大获成功。
It was just murderous row, it was, it was all killer no feller.
简直是一连串的王炸，部部精彩，毫无尿点。
It was like table read, run through for the crew.
就像是剧组的围读和串词排练。
It was like, he had it literally like a perfect score of just crushing every single time.
就像是，他简直有着完美的记录，每一次演出都堪称惊艳。
He just inhabited it so well.
他把这个角色演绎得太淋漓尽致了。
It's funny, sometimes there are, we took a clown class at NYU and it's kind of like, it was like finding what your clown is and your clown might not be goofy, your clown might be arrogant, your clown might be a blowhard, you know what I'm saying?
说来有趣，有时候，我们在纽约大学上过一个小丑表演课，这有点像，就像是寻找你的小丑风格，而你的小丑可能并不滑稽，你的小丑可能很傲慢，你的小丑可能是一个夸夸其谈的人，你知道我在说什么吗？
And it feels like Sandy Rivers is like Alexis's clown or one of his clowns, it was just something that he did so effortlessly and it looked like, It looked like he just knew how to be Sandy Rivers, like from the moment he came on.
感觉桑迪·里弗斯就像是阿历克西斯的小丑角色，或者说是他的小丑形象之一，他演起来毫不费力，看起来就像他从一登场开始就知道该怎么当桑迪·里弗斯一样。
He could have that could have been a whole whole TV show like if there was a TV show about if that if you if like new Metro News one was a TV show he would have been like the Barney of the Metro News one TV.
这完全可以拍成一整部电视剧，如果有一部剧集是关于——如果像“大都会新闻一台”是一部电视剧的话，他就会成为“大都会新闻一台”宇宙里的巴尼。
I mean just like Frazier Crane in Cheers or something where you know like now he was unbelievable.
我的意思是，就像《欢乐酒店》里的弗雷泽·克兰（Frazier Crane）那样，你知道的——天哪，他当时真是不可思议。
So that's our second hymium significant other two episodes in a row right left on the grill is was Taran and now Alexis is in this one and and there will be more yeah we're keeping we're keeping an account.
所以这是我们第二位“老爸”的真命天子/女，连续两集都是这样，上一个是塔兰，现在这一位是阿历克西斯，而且还会有更多，对，我们都在记着账呢。
So a lot of times you would go in for, you know, you go in for these fittings, you know, on a Monday after the table reader or Tuesday after the run through, they asked to see you and you try on a ton of clothes and they just pick.
所以很多时候你会去试装，你知道的，在周一围读之后或者周二串排练之后去试装，他们会叫你过去，然后你试穿大量的衣服，他们来挑选。
And a lot of times, you know, Jason and I, the biggest bonding Jason and I did for nine years was we would often stay in the same jeans and just swap out our shirts or sweaters, but we would change on set because we didn't walk back to our dressing room, right?
很多时候，你知道，我和杰森建立起来的九年里最深厚的友谊，就是我们经常穿着同一条牛仔裤，只是换着穿衬衫或毛衣，但我们在片场直接换衣服，因为我们不会走回化妆间，对吧？
So we were constantly just shirtless talking about things, you know.
所以我们经常光着膀子讨论事情，你知道的。
But in this episode, Ted wears the same thing for two episodes straight.
但在这一集里，泰德连续两集都穿着同一套衣服。
So I remember you going with the Casa, and you're like, well, we gotta find something we really like, because you're gonna be in this for two episodes.
所以我记得你和服装设计一起去，你说，好吧，我们得找一件我们真的很喜欢的衣服，因为你要连着穿两集。
And the fact that we landed on that shirt is astonishing to me.
而我们最终看中那件衬衫，这让我感到震惊。
Astonishing.
太震惊了。
Tell me.
告诉我。
Talk to me about that shirt.
跟我聊聊那件衬衫。
This is not a shirt.
这根本不是一件衬衫。
I don't know in what, because it's not a shirt I would ever wear in my life, ever, back then or today.
我不知道在什么情况下，因为这不是我这辈子任何时候会穿的衬衫，无论是过去还是现在。
But for some reason, I think I, you just, sometimes there's like a weird euphoria in front of the mirror.
但出于某种原因，我想我，你只是，有时候在镜子前会有一种奇怪的欣快感。
Like you put it on the costume design or really likes it, and you're like, yes, right, right?
就像你把它穿上，服装设计也非常喜欢，然后你会说，是的，对吧，对吧？
Right?
对吧？
Right.
对。
looking at the episode at this exact moment.
此时此刻正在看这一集。
I don't even know.
我甚至不知道。
It almost feels like the Tim Robinson thing of like the patterns.
这感觉有点像蒂姆·罗宾逊（Tim Robinson）那种关于图案的梗。
Remember the pattern shirt?
还记得那件花衬衫吗？
What's Dan Flash?
什么是丹·弗拉什（Dan Flash）？
Dan Flash is a pattern shirt.
丹·弗拉什就是卖花衬衫的。
That's what it feels like.
这感觉就是那样。
Long enough, you'd devolve into madness.
时间久了，你就会陷入疯狂。
Well, it was softened a little bit when he had the blazer on.
不过，当他穿上西装外套时，那种感觉稍微被缓和了一点。
I will say that.
我得这么说。
I was delighted to hear my friend Rachel Yamagata's song.
听到我的朋友瑞秋·亚马加塔（Rachel Yamagata）的歌，我感到非常高兴。
That song is so...
那首歌太……
Sorry, I think that's the song.
抱歉，我想那就是那首歌。
Were you friends at that point or did you become friends because we used your music on the show, how did that happen?
你们那个时候已经是朋友了，还是因为我们在剧里用了你们的音乐才成为朋友的？那是怎么回事？
No, I think we were friends.
不，我想我们已经是朋友了。
So I became friends with Rachel because my friend Amy went to college with her manager.
我和瑞秋成为朋友是因为我的朋友艾米和她的经纪人是大学同学。
So we started going to her shows and Rachel and I became friends.
所以我们开始去听她的演唱会，然后我和瑞秋就成了朋友。
And now we're really good friends.
现在我们是非常要好的朋友。
You might have recommended that we use that song.
你可能曾经推荐过我们使用那首歌。
That song is, I think you did.
那首歌，我想是的，你推荐过。
I think I did.
我想是我推荐的。
I will take credit for it.
我来居功。
You did, and it's coming back to me.
的确是你，我想起来了。
And that boy, I was watching it last night and I said, how beautiful is that song?
天哪，我昨晚看的时候还在想，这首歌多美啊。
I mean, it just sets that tone of that perfect song because it's a waltz and it's got this like undercurrent of late night sadness to it.
我的意思是，它完美地定下了那种基调，因为这是一首华尔兹，而且带有一种深夜忧伤的潜流。
Late night sadness and it feels, yeah, that's it.
深夜的忧伤，而且感觉，对，就是这样。
It feels sort of sleepy and sad, but a little dizzy.
感觉有点困倦和悲伤，但又有点头晕目眩。
Like there's something about it that was the perfect moment to perfectly landed where Robin got to as she made that phone call to tell.
就好像它的某种特质，在罗宾打电话给泰德的那一刻，成为了完美契合的完美落点。
That was our big challenge.
那是我们最大的挑战。
How do you make the sale that she would choose that night to call him and that was what that act of that episode, that 20 hours earlier tried to do.
你怎么能说服观众，让她在那天晚上选择打电话给他，而这正是那一集的那个桥段、也就是20小时前试图做到的事情。
And also little touches like how the enormous glass of wine she pours herself, you know?
还有一些小细节，比如她给自己倒的那杯超大杯红酒，你知道吗？
Like there's just something.
就好像有什么东西在里面。
Yeah.
对。
We get into those nights where you just feel particularly self-pitying and lonely.
我们都会经历那种特别自怨自艾、倍感孤独的夜晚。
Yeah, and it's again, like that two in the morning thing of like, I'll always feel this way.
对，这又回到了那种凌晨两点时的状态，就觉得：我永远都会这种感觉。
Yeah.
对。
You can very easily convince yourself at two in the morning that I will always feel like this.
在凌晨两点，你很容易让自己相信，我以后一直都会是这种感觉。
The 20s are you don't have enough experience having gotten through those nights.
20多岁的时候，你还没有足够的经历去熬过那些夜晚。
Yes.
是的。
So those nights when they come feel the dark night of the soul is particularly dark.
所以当那些夜晚来临的时候，那种灵魂的至暗时刻会显得格外黑暗。
Agree.
同意。
And I think you haven't seen enough of those through to remember what the other side feels like.
而且我觉得你经历过的还不够多，无法记住雨过天晴是什么感觉。
Yeah.
对。
So you make bad decisions sometimes.
所以有时你会做出错误的决定。
Yeah.
对。
And you think, yeah, you chase things that maybe you shouldn't.
你会觉得，对，你会去追求一些或许不该追求的东西。
And she's chasing something too.
而她也在追求着什么。
She knows Ted's still with Victoria at that point until he lies and says he isn't, which he needed to sort of make the whole story work, which boy, re-watching that moment, that's a big old liar right there from Ted.
她当时知道泰德还和维多利亚在一起，直到泰德撒谎说没有，为了让整个故事行得通他不得不这么做，天哪，重看那一幕时，泰德简直是个老撒谎精。
And he thinks it's a lie, the ends justify the means, the ends are I'm going to marry Robin and this will just all come out in the wash.
他觉得这是一个善意的谎言，目的正当手段就可以不择手段，目的就是我要娶罗宾，最后这一切都会烟消云散的。
And boy, it does not work out that way at that moment.
天哪，那一刻事情可不是这么发展的。
Well, it almost also feels like I'm gonna break up Victoria in six hours, so what's the harm in changing around the timeline a little bit?
嗯，这也让人感觉就像是：反正我六小时后就要和维多利亚分手了，稍微调整一下时间线又有什么关系呢？
Arguing the semantics, the way we argue the semantics of things to tour advantage, and then sometimes Karma goes, nope.
玩弄字眼，为了对我们有利而玩弄字眼，然后有时因果报应就会说：想得美。
Right.
对。
It doesn't always, but sometimes it does, and that isn't how Ted and Robin were meant to to begin, and it is 2 p.m.
虽然不总是这样，但有时确实如此，而这并不是泰德和罗宾命中注定的开始，当时是下午两点。
He musted me, fell in love with you, knew who you were sitting.
他……爱上了你，知道你坐在哪里。
And now, commercials!
现在，是广告时间！
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈德曼，《Hyper-Fixed》播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会聆听听众的烦恼并试着为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30, and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如这些烦恼：我30岁了，却害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我倒车时不能调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car-related problems.
我们也解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果你有什么烦恼，我们不仅会帮你解决，还会揭露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这就是来自 Radiotopia 的《Hyper-Fixed》播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
你可以在各大播客平台或访问 HyperFixedPod.com 找到它。
End of commercials?
广告结束？
Back to show.
回到节目。
they know that's not really what's going on.
他们知道那并不是真正发生的事情。
But they jump into it with such gusto that two of them come in the morning.
但他们以极大的热情投入其中，以至于在凌晨两点才回到家。
And she comes over with like, she got a lot of stuff at the late night.
她过来的时候，带了很多深夜买的东西。
You got a lot of stuff at the Bodega.
你在小卖部买了好多东西。
Yeah.
对。
That can't be like the best quality.
那不可能是质量最好的东西。
Yeah.
对。
And she's like, once I'm lying and it's just so funny.
然后她说，一旦我开始撒谎，就太搞笑了。
They abandoned the juicing immediately.
他们立刻放弃了榨汁。
Will juice and what does he say to, we're juicing his friends to the cow driver.
要榨汁，他对……他是怎么对网约车司机说的，我们要给朋友榨汁。
We're juicing his friends.
我们要给朋友榨汁。
It's so funny.
太搞笑了。
I love future narrator Ted's presence in this one where just every so often he'll just be like, go to bed.
我喜欢未来旁白泰德在这一集里的存在感，他每隔一段时间就会说：去睡觉吧。
It's like he's watching it with us.
就像他和我们一起在看一样。
He's like the football announcer like, no, they shouldn't run that play.
他就像美式足球解说员一样：不，他们不应该打那个战术。
Stop it.
住手。
Don't do that.
别那样做。
I also love when Marshall pops in with, it's too late for juice.
我也很喜欢马修突然冒出一句：现在喝果汁太晚了。
It's too late for juice.
现在喝果汁太晚了。
It's so funny.
太搞笑了。
It's, you know, I love, there's certain movies like this, too, where you go into the movie knowing all the bad things that are going to happen and the joy is in watching exactly how bad it gets and how badly they unfold.
你知道的，我喜欢，某些电影也是这样，你明知所有糟糕的事情都会发生还要去看，而乐趣就在于看事情究竟能变得多糟糕，以及它们是如何一步步搞砸的。
This episode is like that, right?
这一集就是这样，对吧？
This episode is you're going in there, like, no one went into Titanic, like, I wonder what's going to happen to that ship.
这一集就像是，你看的时候，没有人会去看《泰坦尼克号》然后说：我不知道那艘船会发生什么。
This episode is kind of like, the ship's going to sink.
这一集有点像：这艘船就是要沉的。
It's just the details along the way.
妙就妙在过程中的种种细节。
I mean, in that way, it's both classical theatre, but it's also a bit of a horror film in some ways.
我的意思是，从这个意义上说，它既是古典戏剧，但在某些方面也算是一部恐怖片。
late at night, they're scared.
深夜里，他们很害怕。
I love the, shout out to John Swahart, our composer, like the really, because we, Rachel, oh my God, it's great, the music placements, that's Andy Gowen and Josh Radner bringing me those songs, Andy Gowen's our music supervisor.
我喜欢，向我们的作曲家约翰·斯瓦哈特致敬，比如那种真的，因为我们，瑞秋，天哪，太棒了，音乐的编排，那是安迪·高恩和乔什·拉德纳带给我的这些歌曲，安迪·高恩是我们的音乐总监。
The composer, if you listen to the score, it's very like, there's kind of like a moonlight sonata, kind of like creepy sort of late at night classical, but there's some tone of late at night-ness that is said by that score that is really great.
作曲家，如果你听配乐，它非常像，有点像月光奏鸣曲，那种毛骨悚然的深夜古典乐，但那段配乐传达出了一种非常棒的深夜氛围。
So shout out to John Swahart on that one.
所以要向约翰·斯瓦哈特致敬。
What, I remember Neil and Jason loved, like they get in a fight, right?
什么，我记得尼尔和杰森非常喜欢，比如他们吵了一架，对吧？
Like they get in a, and they have to scream at each other over that table, right?
比如他们陷入了，他们必须隔着那张桌子对彼此尖叫，对吧？
Yeah, I know what you're gonna say.
对，我知道你要说什么。
I know what line.
我知道是哪句台词。
It's, I'll show you things you've never seen before from Jason.
就是，我要让你见识一下杰森从没让你见过的事情。
Is that the one you're thinking?
是这句吗你想的是这句？
Yes, he says that, but I have a different favorite, Jim or Jabber improv that he threw at him a moment, which is, I used to box in the army.
是的，他说了那句，但我最喜欢的其实是吉姆或杰森即兴发挥的另一个瞬间，也就是：我在军队里练过拳击。
Is that is that Neil or Jason Jason Jason both of those in rapid succession the those were his lines, right?
那是，那是尼尔还是杰森？杰森，杰森，这两句紧接着出现，那是他的台词对吧？
I think he just improvised those For some reason the one I caught was I'll show you things you What's that mean?
我想他只是即兴发挥的。碰巧我捕捉到的是：我要让你见识一下你……那是什么意思？你可以在YouTube上找到他们两个人的完整未采用片段。
You can find that on on YouTube you can find the full sort out take of just the two of them Yeah, there's also right now take if you look up the bloopers of him and there would Kobe pours that giant bottle of wine and starts drinking it, and she's just drinking it and drinking it, and you hear Pam fry me go.
对，如果你去找他和科比的NG镜头，也会有当前片段，科比倒了那大瓶红酒开始喝，她就一直喝一直喝，你能听到帕姆·弗莱曼说：还在继续，显然科比在想，帕姆什么时候喊卡，而帕姆只是说：我打算让你把整瓶都喝完，然后她就想：见鬼。
It goes on, not Kobe, clearly is wondering, when's Pam gonna call cut and Pam just says, I'm just gonna have you drink the whole thing, and she's like, God damn it.
这是一个非常有趣的幕后花絮，你能找到它，是的，每个人在这集里都拿出了最高水平。
It's a very funny, heavy and blooper, you can find it, yeah, everyone was bringing their A game on this one.
我也很喜欢巴尼的支线任务（如果你愿意这么称呼的话），也就是：我们要让今晚成为传奇，我要反驳泰德妈妈的那个陈词滥调。
And I also love Barney's kind of side quest, if you will, of like, we're gonna make this night legendary, and I'm gonna disprove this truism from Ted's mom.
我喜欢他们所有人都知道泰德妈妈的口头禅。
And I love that they all know Ted's mom sign.
你知道泰德妈妈总是说什么。
You know what Ted's mom always says.
整群朋友都用这个来重新构建。
The whole group of friends reframes with that one.
他可能会说，我要证明它是错的。
He's probably, I'm going to prove it wrong.
有很多次，当巴尼想在外面多玩一会儿，他就会说：哦，莫斯比太太说……泰德可能曾试图劝说巴尼不要做可怕的事情。
That's so many times when Barney wants to stay out and he's like, oh, Mrs. Mosby says, Ted has probably tried to talk Barney out of terrible things.
但有了这句话，我听到泰德此刻并不比巴尼好到哪里去。
But with that phrase and I hear Ted is no better than Barney in this moment.
我的意思是，这有点像巴尼的整体元叙事，他是一个在最后关头从帽子里变出东西的魔术师，对吧？
I mean, it's kind of like Barney's whole meta narrative is he's a magician who pulls it out of the hat at the last moment, right?
就像他实际上只是，只要我们决定，随时都能把铅变成金子。
Like he's really just, we can turn lead into gold any time if we just decide.
而且甚至不需要是性。
And it doesn't even have to be sex.
不需要那么刺激。
It doesn't have to be exciting.
可以很诡异。
It can be weird.
比如韩版猫王为莉莉献唱情歌就足够好了。
Like, Korean Elvis serenading Lily is like good enough.
舔自由钟，那不是性的东西。
Licking the Liberty Bell, that's not sexual.
听起来像，但其实不是。
It sounds sexual, but it's not.
但对，我觉得只是它以前从未被做过。
But yeah, I think just it had you have never been done before.
他在寻找——
He's in search of- New is always better, right?
新鲜总是好的，对吧？
New is always better.
新鲜总是好的。
He's in search of the legendary.
他在寻找传奇。
And sometimes that's women.
有时候是女性。
And sometimes it's not.
有时候又不是。
And I really like how I thought of this watching this episode.
我真的很喜欢我看这一集时的这种想法。
The characters are very aware of, the characters are aware they're in a story, in a way.
剧中的角色非常清楚，某种程度上，角色们知道自己身处一个故事中。
So the characters react as if they know a future person has re-enlivened that is sort of making them relive the story and they're vaguely aware of the stories happening as it's happening.
所以这些角色的反应就好像他们知道未来有人重新激活了这段经历，就像是在让他们重温这个故事，而且他们隐约意识到了故事正在发生。
And like Barney is saying, like, you know, there's a freeze frame after Lily kicks Korean Elvis in the nards and freeze frame there, says that would become known as the name, like Lily kicked me and all this much.
就像巴尼说的，你知道的，莉莉踢了韩国猫王（Elvis）的要害之后出现了一个定格画面，定格画面里说，这以后会被命名为，比如“莉莉踢了我”诸如此类。
And immediately you come out of the freeze frame, Barney's like, Hey, guys, remember that time?
紧接着画面从定格中恢复，巴尼就说：“嘿，伙计们，还记得那次吗？”
Lily kicked her, you know, it's the nards have five seconds ago.
莉莉踢了他，你知道的，那是五秒钟前的事。
This idea of like branding things, we will remember this future us will tell this story.
这种给事情打上烙印的想法，我们会记住这一点，未来的我们会讲述这个故事。
Hey, Ted, don't do this.
嘿，泰德，别这么做。
You're screwing it up for future you future you if you get with Robin does not want to start your life together on a crime.
你在毁了未来的自己，如果你和罗宾在一起，未来的你可不想以一件罪过开始你们的共同生活。
If there's just this weird kind of meta narrative thing, even the whole show Joe starts with, you know, we're gonna tell, I'm gonna tell my kids about this night.
就是有这种奇怪的元叙事设定，甚至整部剧一开始，你知道的，我们打算讲，我要把那天晚上的事讲给我孩子们听。
Like, he, Ted in particular is, and Barney too, are very, they all are.
就像他，尤其是泰德，还有巴尼，他们非常——所有人都这样。
You can make the case, they all are, they mythologize their life.
你可以这么说，他们所有人都在将自己的生活神话化。
In the moment.
就在当下。
They, Jean Shepherd their life.
他们用让·谢泼德（Jean Shepherd）的方式来对待生活。
They make it, you know, what's that?
他们把它变成，你知道的，什么？
There's that Richard Royal line, or someone said this, if you don't mythologize your life, you'll pathologize your life.
理查德·罗伊（Richard Royal）有句名言，或者有人说过，如果你不把自己的生活神话化，你就会把生活病理化。
Like, it's actually really, it's really healthy.
所以这其实真的很，真的很健康。
to look at your life in this kind of narrative way.
以这种叙事的方式来看待你的生活。
So you can also see, if you mythologize your life, if you look at your life narratively, you can see that, I think it's really healthy, like one of the features of depression say, is that you feel like nothing's ever gonna change and nothing's ever gonna, it's static, it's never gonna change.
所以你也能看到，如果你将生活神话化，如果你从叙事的角度来看待生活，你会发现——我认为这真的很健康，比如抑郁症的一个特征就是，你会觉得事情永远不会改变，永远不会……它是静态的，永远不会改变。
But if you're in a story, you know that stories are always changing, characters are always growing, characters are always moving through things and getting onto other adventures.
但如果你身处一个故事中，你就知道故事总是在变化的，角色总是在成长，角色总是在经历各种事情并开启其他冒险。
And I think it's actually, you know, we don't want to be grandiose about it, but I think there is something healthy about looking at your life from a narrative context.
而且我认为，你知道的，我们不必把它说得多么宏大，但我认为从叙事的角度来看待生活确实有益健康。
But you have to hover a little over your life to do that.
但为此你必须稍微跳脱出自己的生活。
I think that's right.
我认为这很对。
You have to be seeking some kind of meaning or pattern in your life in the moment to even imagine that a meaning and pattern will emerge later.
你必须在当下就去寻找生活中的某种意义或模式，甚至去想象这种意义和模式稍后会显现出来。
Right.
没错。
I think that's what the show is.
我想这就是这部剧的魅力所在。
And the characters are aware of that.
角色们也意识到了这一点。
And it's a little chicken or egg.
这就有点像先有鸡还是先有蛋。
It's like, you can be on the hunt for meaning and pattern, or you can have detected a lot of meaning in patterns, but just honoring that they are there.
就像你可以去寻找意义和模式，或者你已经发现了许多意义和模式，但只是去承认它们的存在。
But even as, and what Ted's doing in this one, he's trying to change the meaning with words in the moment and saying, well, if I'm gonna break up with her tomorrow, it's the same thing as if I already broke up with her, which he doesn't know, that's why she was calling.
但即使在此时，泰德在这集中做的事，他试图当场用言语改变这种意义，并说，好吧，如果我明天要和她分手，这就跟我已经和她分手了一样——而他并不知道这一点，这就是为什么她会打电话来。
He does not know that.
他根本不知道。
And he is so rationalizing himself into what he wants in that moment.
他是在极力为自己辩解，以得到他在那一刻想要的东西。
And he's trying to kind of create a different meaning that isn't really the truth and the truth.
他试图创造一种并非真正真相的不同意义，而真相是……
It kind of, there's kind of an organ transplant rejection happens there.
这其中有点像是发生了器官移植排异反应。
That's an attempt to turn it into this other narrative.
那是试图把它变成另一种叙事的尝试。
And it's like, nope, I'm sorry.
结果就像是，不，抱歉。
That's not gonna fit here.
这在这里行不通。
I think it's funny how, like Ted takes the juice thing literally in that he goes and buys vegetables.
我觉得很有趣的是，泰德把榨汁那件事当真了，所以他去买了蔬菜。
But it's clearly, as we said, it's not about the juice.
但正如我们所说，这显然与果汁无关。
Except for Marshall, he's like.
除了马歇尔，他当时就像是。
And then she's going to make you some delicious juice, like you're helpless, like you're walking into the lion's den, who could resist that delicious juice.
然后她会给你做一些美味的果汁，就好像你很无助，就像你走进了虎穴，谁能抗拒那种美味的果汁呢。
He's going to lure you in with carrot celery juice.
他要用胡萝卜芹菜汁来诱惑你。
Yeah.
对。
And it's funny that Ted buys all this stuff because it goes along with the narrative.
有趣的是，泰德买了所有这些东西，因为这符合剧情发展。
He wants to believe that's what's happening.
他愿意相信这就是正在发生的事情。
So he's like, if I buy these vegetables, then surely that's the story.
所以他想，如果我买了这些蔬菜，那这肯定就是故事的发展了。
It's almost like the vegetables and the fruit are his armor.
这几乎就像蔬菜和水果是他的盔甲。
Like if I hold these in front of me.
就像如果我把这些举在身前。
I'm going over here in good faith because she said, let's make some juice, right?
我是怀着诚意来这里的，因为她说，我们来榨点汁吧，对吧？
I will say, just a shout out to Kobe, fantastic bit of acting when he said, when Ted tells Robin, we broke up and she's the smiling while saying the other words, A plus, a plus super star acting.
我要说，向寇比（Cobie）致敬，当泰德告诉罗宾我们分手了而她一边说着别的话一边微笑着时，那段演技简直绝了，A加，A加超级巨星级的演技。
just hilarious and like full of like it's like it's like it's a moment that is electric because you're like there oh this is on but it's also funny but it's also good acting like it's yeah it's yeah I thought the same thing yeah so great I liked when when Ted is on the phone with Lily and Lily's talking some like kind of ethical sense into him I remember I was doing something like like like, damn it, like, which I think I stole from Dustin Hoffman somewhere and could see.
简直太搞笑了，而且充满了那种——就像是——就像这是一个充满电荷的时刻，因为你会觉得，哦，要来真的了，但它也很搞笑，同时演技又很好，所以——是的，我也是这么想的，太棒了。我喜欢当泰德和莉莉通电话时，莉莉用某种道德感来劝说他时，我记得我当时在做一件事，像是——“该死，像这样”——我想我是从达斯汀·霍夫曼（Dustin Hoffman）那里偷师的，能看出来。
Like, there's some sort of like- Good thing to steal from.
就像是某种——是个值得借鉴的好桥段。
Damn it, like, you know, I really like the, that face is not for her, he's not doing it audibly.
“该死，像这样”，你知道的，我真的很喜欢那种表情不是为了她做的，他不是出声做出来的。
It's just his own internal combustion, you know?
那只是他内心的熊熊燃烧，你知道吗？
Yeah, I love that moment too.
对，我也很喜欢那个时刻。
That is an excellent half of a phone call acting, which of course, you're not really acting with Alison standing at the moment, someone is off screen reading her lines with you and you were very in it in this episode, you were very in the dilemma and I will say, just to defend Ted for a second, he's not just trying to have sex with a pretty girl.
那是一段极佳的“半边电话”演技，当然，你当时并没有真的和艾莉森（Alyson）对戏，有人在画外帮你念台词，而你完全沉浸在这一集里，你深深陷入了这个两难境地，而且我要说，为泰德辩护一句，他不仅仅是想和漂亮女孩上床。
He does love Robin, like there is that other side to it.
他是真的爱罗宾，里面还有另一层因素。
He is imagining something deeper that will come from this.
他在想象这件事会带来更深层次的发展。
This isn't like drunk at McLaren's making out with, yeah, the girl who just got broken up with, yeah.
这不像是在麦克拉伦酒吧（McLaren's）喝醉了跟……刚分手的女孩亲热，对吧。
Barney.
巴尼。
He's not, yeah, he's not being Barney.
他不是，对，他没有在扮演巴尼。
There is some, Ted does not not have a point, if you know what I mean?
有些东西——泰德并不是完全没有道理，如果你明白我的意思的话？
There is something there, which is what makes this so interesting of a dilemma, I think.
里面确实有些东西，这也是为什么我觉得这个两难境地如此有趣。
Well, it's also you guys constructed it in such a way that you brought the long distance headache of it to the boiling point where it's like, I can't connect with her, I feel so far away from her.
嗯，这也是因为你们把异地恋带来的头疼问题构建到了沸点，让人感觉，我和她无法沟通，我感觉离她好远。
That seed's been planted.
这颗种子已经种下了。
Yeah, it's really, Yeah, it's masterfully constructed to have all of it kind of come to a head and explode in this episode.
对，真的，是的，它的构建堪称大师级，让所有这些情绪在这一集中汇聚到顶点并爆发出来。
It's engineered, tip of the hat, dramaturgically, to you guys.
这是精心设计的，向你们的戏剧结构致敬。
Thank you.
谢谢。
It's a huge shout out to Carter Bay, so I do believe, I feel like this one was more him than me, although I think we both really loved working on this one.
这要大大感谢卡特·贝斯（Carter Bays），我确实相信，我觉得这一集他贡献的更多，虽然我觉得我们俩都非常喜欢制作这一集。
But the idea of the ghostly Victoria, I feel like that was Carter, because I just remember being so excited about it in a way that makes me feel like it wasn't my idea because it was my idea.
但关于幽灵维多利亚（Victoria）的想法，我感觉那是卡特想出来的，因为我只记得当时对它感到无比兴奋，这种感觉让我觉得这不是我的主意，尽管它确实是我的主意。
I'm probably like, yeah, it's okay.
我当时大概会说，好吧，这还不错。
Rule of writing number one, everything's better with a ghost.
写作第一法则，加个鬼魂什么都好说。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
It just makes it very exciting.
这会让事情变得非常刺激。
There's a ghost in this episode and you're like, oh, I didn't know that they're doing ghosts on the CBS sitcom at eight o'clock.
这一集里有个鬼魂，然后你会觉得，哦，我不知道他们要在CBS情景喜剧里在八点钟档搞鬼魂这一套。
I didn't know we're doing Hamlet here.
我不知道我们在这里演《哈姆雷特》。
I'd like to point out that I think I could be wrong.
我想指出的是，我可能记错了。
I think this might be your first right, right after the original right, right?
我觉得这可能是你们第一次“对，对”，就在最初的那个“对，对”之后，对吧？
And it's subtle.
而且这很微妙。
It's right as you're getting on top of of Rod, Ted again, Robin, you're kissing, and she says something, can you?
就在你压住罗宾——泰德再次压住罗宾，你们在接吻，然后她说了一些话，你能吗？
I can't believe that we're making it right, right?
我不敢相信我们真的做到了，对吧？
It's great.
太棒了。
You guys were really electric in that whole thing.
你们俩在整段戏里的表现都极具张力。
It was just like, what's gonna happen?
简直就是，接下来会发生什么？
It's a suspense episode.
这是一集悬疑片。
It's a ghost story.
这是一个鬼故事。
It's a little bit of a horror movie, and there's a Korean Elvis.
还有点恐怖片的味道，而且里面还有一个韩国猫王。
It kind of is everything you could ever ask for in 22 minutes of TV, I think.
我觉得这基本上涵盖了你在22分钟电视剧里能要求的一切。
I like this one.
我很喜欢这一集。
I loved when Marshall says, you just got burned Phonics style.
我最喜欢马歇尔说：“你刚刚用自然拼读法被喷了。”
Phonics style.
自然拼读法。
I guarantee you that was Chris or Phil.
我向你保证那是克里斯（Chris）或菲尔（Phil）想的。
That was for you.
那是专门给你的。
That could be a huge one.
这可能是一个很大的梗。
It could have been me, but I think it was Lord and Miller.
也可能是我，但我认为是菲尔和克里斯。
Because if that was me, it's just me stealing their verbatim, I think, their vernacular.
因为如果那是我，那也只是我原封不动地偷用了他们的原话，他们的日常用语。
That's a very Chris and Phil shout out to them.
这绝对是克里斯和菲尔的风格，向他们致敬。
When did you guys come up with the kind of ultimate plot point, which is the phone switcheroo?
你们是什么时候想出那种终极情节转折点的，也就是手机调包恶作剧？
I mean, again, I think technologically, we were like, sometimes that happens because it's 2006.
我的意思是，再说一次，我觉得在技术层面上，我们当时就觉得，有时候事情就是那样，因为那是2006年。
I think it was how do we, what really undoes Ted here, and it could really only be that, right?
我觉得当时是我们在想，究竟是什么，是什么真正毁了这里的泰德，而且真的只能是那个，对吧？
I think it was just by process of elimination, like what can, what will destroy everything?
我觉得这只是通过排除法得出的，比如有什么能、什么会摧毁一切？
If Robin hears directly from Victoria, it destroys everything.
如果罗宾直接从维多利亚那里听到消息，那就一切都毁了。
And we just, I think concocted a way that could happen.
而我们只是，我觉得我们捏造了一种可能发生的方式。
She's not gonna walk in the door.
她不会自己走进来。
She didn't get on a plane from Germany to come surprise Ted at Robin's apartment at him, right?
她没有坐飞机从德国来罗宾的公寓给泰德一个惊喜，对吧？
It had to be that.
只能是那样。
I think we just got there.
我想我们就是这么想到的。
But when we got, when watching it last night for the first time in many years, I was, I was delighted by it because I was like surprising, but inevitable.
但当我们，当昨天时隔多年第一次重看它时，我，我对此感到很高兴，因为我觉得这很意外，但又在情理之中。
Yep.
没错。
And maybe a little technologically outdated, but, uh, but it works, right?
也许在技术上有点过时了，但是，呃，不过它奏效了，对吧？
It works.
它奏效了。
We never said it was in 2006, but when he, when he comes out there and, and she's on the phone and her whole energy is so different.
我们从没说过那是2006年，但当他，当他走到外面，然后，她正在打电话，她的整个状态完全不同。
And I, you know, I remember, uh, Ben Lee, my, my dear friend, who I used to make music with as Radner and Lee as I'm, it's plugging my other project.
然后，你知道，我记得，呃，本·李，我的，我的挚友，我以前曾和他一起做音乐，当时叫拉德纳和李，顺便宣传一下我的其他项目。
But he told me that we used to talk about how bad we are or would be at being like bad dudes.
但他告诉我，我们以前经常讨论我们在扮演混蛋这方面有多糟糕，或者会有多糟糕。
Like I never wrote this song, but I thought it was kind of like a good line for a country song to say I dance poorly when I dance with the devil.
就像我从来没写过这首歌，但我觉得对于乡村歌曲来说，这算是一句不错的歌词：当我与魔鬼共舞时，我舞姿拙劣。
Oh, that is a good line.
哦，那真是一句好词。
Like my moves don't work when I'm dancing with the devil.
就像当我与魔鬼共舞时，我的舞步就不起作用了。
And Ben told me, he said, you know, I tried on like the costume of like a dickish rocker for like a couple months.
本告诉我，他说，你知道，我曾试着假装穿上混蛋摇滚乐手的戏服，大概持续了几个月。
And everyone was like, what are you doing?
然后每个人都说，你在干什么？
You can't do this.
你不能这么做。
But other people who that's their whole brand, they just start off, they do it.
但其他人，这本就是他们的全部人设，他们一开始就这么做，他们就是这么干的。
And not only do they do it, they seem to get away with it for quite a while, right?
不仅如此，他们似乎还能逍遥法外很长一段时间，对吧？
Yeah.
是啊。
Yes.
没错。
But if you're, if you're constitutionally a nice, kind, thoughtful person, it's going to eat you alive.
但如果你，如果你生性是个善良、仁慈、体贴的人，这会把你活活折磨死。
Karma gets you quicker.
因果报应来得更快。
Karma gets you much faster and I feel like how many times is Barney like given a false name had a whole false thing and he just seems to get away with it because he never claimed to be anything different whereas Ted actually the ethics does matter to him he does want to be a good guy he is constitutionally honest and when he tries to deceive Victoria and himself on a huge level and Robin, it boomerang so fast back at him.
因果报应会更快地找上你，我觉得巴尼有多少次用假名字、编造一整套谎言，而他似乎总能逃脱惩罚，因为他从没标榜自己是什么好人，而泰德，道德对他来说真的很重要，他确实想成为一个好人，他生性诚实，当他试图在极大程度上欺骗维多利亚、他自己以及罗宾时，报应以极快的速度反弹到了他身上。
It's really true because like Barney, even though there's definitely a heart and soul in there as we've discussed and as we see as the seasons go on, Barney's in the armor building business.
这真的千真万确，因为就像巴尼一样，尽管正如我们所讨论的以及随着剧集发展我们所看到的，他的内心深处其实是有灵魂和温情的，但巴尼一直在从事建立心灵盔甲的买卖。
Barney's building armor starting with that suit and the more bad crap you do, the more you build up your armor I think and when you're the guy that doesn't do the bad stuff and do it once, you get burned and it hits you and there's no armor there and that's kind of what the end of this episode is and why it's why a future into narrator Ted frames the story the way he does.
巴尼从那套西装开始就在构筑盔甲，你做的混蛋事越多，我猜你的盔甲就越厚；而当你是个平时不做坏事、偶尔做一次的人时，你就会遭到反噬，它会狠狠击中你，而那里根本没有盔甲，这正是本集结尾的意义所在，也是为什么未来的旁白泰德会以那种方式来构建这个故事。
He gets burned.
他遭到了反噬。
But that's what I mean though about how I met your mother being a moral or ethical universe where you can't get away with it that long.
但这就是我的意思，关于《老爸老妈浪漫史》是一个怎样的道德或伦理世界，在那里你不可能逃脱惩罚太久。
There's some sort of come up and for unethical behavior.
不道德的行为总会有某种报应。
By the way, here's another good country song title.
顺便说一句，这里有另一个不错的乡村歌曲歌名。
Nothing good happens after 2 a.m.
凌晨两点之后没有好事发生。
Please somebody write that country song and then send it to us.
请哪位写一下这首乡村歌曲，然后寄给我们。
It's a good one.
这是一个好歌名。
We have reached a point in our show that we like to call questions and observations from a clinical psychologist who's never seen how I met your mother and also happens to be married to Josh.
我们的节目现在进行到一个环节，我们喜欢称之为“来自从未看过《老爸老妈浪漫史》的临床心理学家的提问与观察，她碰巧还是乔许的妻子”。
I like this episode because it shows Ted wrestling with a moral dilemma.
我喜欢这一集，因为它展现了泰德与道德困境的抗争。
We get to see is conscience at work.
我们得以看到他的良知在起作用。
Lillian Marshall sort of represent the angel on his shoulder, his moral compass, and Barney is, you know, a little more devilish, let's say.
莉莉和马歇尔有点像他肩上的天使，代表着他的道德罗盘，而巴尼，你知道，可以说是更像个小恶魔。
And it's interesting to watch Ted stuck in between with Victoria as a literal manifestation of him negotiating between the two parts of himself, the part that just wants to say whatever and be with Robin and feels like the right thing to do is to follow his heart.
看着泰德夹在中间，而维多利亚作为他内心两部分之间博弈的实体化呈现，这非常有趣：一部分只想不管不顾地和罗宾在一起，觉得遵从内心才是正确的事；
And the part that knows that the right thing to do is to to be honest.
而另一部分则深知正确的事应该是坦诚相告。
And I just think as an audience member, watching Ted go through this makes him even more multi-dimensional, even more human.
而我只是觉得，作为观众，看着泰德经历这一切，让他的形象变得更加多维、更加人性化。
We all have that devil and angel on our shoulders.
我们每个人的肩膀上都有那个恶魔和天使。
It's relatable.
这很有共鸣。
And then even further watching him mess up and get burned, that too is relatable.
而且更进一步地看他搞砸事情并遭到反噬，这也是能够引发共鸣的。
So I just think this episode while painful to watch goes a long way in making Ted a character that feels more real to us.
所以我只是觉得这一集虽然看起来很痛苦，但在让泰德成为一个对我们而言更真实的角色方面，起到了很大的作用。
That's so smart, and that was very much the intention.
太精辟了，这绝对是我们的初衷。
And we've said it a couple of times this season, it's really interesting the moments we picked to show that Ted messes up to, and that he's not gonna be giving some amazing speech every week, he's not always going to want the right thing.
我们在这个季度已经说过好几次了，我们精心挑选这些时刻来展现泰德也会搞砸事情，而且他不会每周都发表什么精彩绝伦的演讲，他也不总是会做出正确的事情。
Underneath all of this nefariousness in this episode is something true-hearted and sweet.
在这集的种种卑劣行径背后，隐藏着一些真挚而甜美的东西。
At the core of it, Ted really does love Robin, and he really did love her before he ever met Victoria.
归根结底，泰德确实爱罗宾，而且早在遇到维多利亚之前他就已经爱上她了。
But he's not doing the right thing here, and I do think that humanized the same.
但他在这里做的不是正确的事，我确实认为这让人性化了许多。
I, this is one of my favorite 10 episodes of season one and maybe of the series because of what exactly what Jordan, I couldn't say it better myself.
我，这是我最喜欢的《老爸老妈浪漫史》第一季的十集之一，也许也是整部剧中我最喜欢的之一，正是因为乔丹所说的那些，我自己都说不出比这更好的了。
That's what makes this one so interesting and it's Ted so human.
这就是让这一集如此有趣的原因，它让泰德显得如此有人情味。
And I feel like your performance in this one, you felt it, you felt excited acting in this episode and I could see more.
我觉得你在这集里的表演，你感受到了，你在这一集里演得很带劲，我能看出更多。
Well, it's also true.
嗯，这也是事实。
Like if I, if someone presents themselves to me as this kind of like infallible kind of exemplar of moral rectitude, I find it actually not only boring, but like quite suspicious, right?
比如如果我，如果有人向我展示他自己是一个无可挑剔的道德正直典范，我不仅会觉得无聊，而且会觉得相当可疑，对吧？
I think there's something about, like, piety is very kind of overrated and annoying.
我觉得某种程度上，假正经是非常被高估且令人讨厌的。
But if someone presents, hey, I'm vulnerable, I'm flawed, let me tell you three ways I messed up.
但如果有人展现出，嘿，我很脆弱，我有缺点，让我告诉你我搞砸过的三件事。
Do you want to connect?
你想建立连接吗？
Do you want to have a conversation?
你想聊聊吗？
Or can I tell you what I learned?
或者我可以告诉你我学到了什么吗？
That is how we solicit kind of, we get people on our team by showing how human we are, not how perfect we are, infallible we are, that all that does is kind of make us turn on ourselves and go, oh, I'm not like this guy, I'm not like this person, right?
这才是我们如何寻求认同的方式，我们通过展示我们有多么人性化，而不是我们有多完美、多无可挑剔来把人们拉进我们的阵营，因为所有那些完美只会让我们开始自我怀疑并觉得，哦，我可不像这家伙，我可不像这个人，对吧？
But I think also when you're creating a character that you're presumably, we didn't know at at the time, but gonna follow for eight more seasons.
但我觉得同时，当你塑造一个你大概率要陪伴观众走过接下来八个季度的角色时——虽然当时我们还不知道会这样。
You wanna feel like they're, I think that's one of the things I'm most proud of about Ted is that he, while his heart was in the right place, his feet were often pointed in the wrong direction, or his head was going one way, his heart was going another way, his dick was going another way.
你希望觉得他们是——我觉得这是我对泰德最引以为傲的一点，那就是尽管他的内心是善良的，但他的双脚往往指向错误的方向，或者他的脑袋想着往一边去，他的心却想着另一边，他的下半身又想着另一个方向。
He was a man at odds with himself a lot, But he ultimately learned, he had to learn patience, he had to learn, he had to fail more, he had to struggle.
他是一个经常与自己较劲的人，但他最终学会了，他不得不学会耐心，他不得不学会，他必须经历更多的失败，他必须苦苦挣扎。
And I would say by that when I started playing Ted, I also had to get a little scuffed up more.
我想说的是，当我开始扮演泰德时，我也必须让自己经历更多磕磕绊绊。
And I think we all, I think that's a good thing to teach, whether it's your kids or anyone else you're teaching like, don't bemoan your failures.
我觉得我们所有人，我觉得这是一件很好的教育事情，无论是对你的孩子还是你教导的任何人，比如不要哀叹你的失败。
Your failures are where your character gets forged.
你的失败正是塑造你性格的地方。
Yes.
是的。
You know, and I think that's what he's telling his kids on some level, like your old man really stepped in it in this one.
你知道，我觉得这也就是他在某种程度上对他的孩子们所说的话，比如你们的老爸这次真的闯大祸了。
Yeah, and he's not hiding it from them.
是的，而且他并没有对他们隐瞒。
He's not being pious.
他没有装腔作势。
He's not being falsely pious.
他没有虚伪地装正经。
And he's not hiding it from them.
而且他也没有对他们隐瞒这一点。
And that should solicit a kind of trust from his kids.
这应该会赢得他孩子们的一种信任。
Like I'm an honest, you know, both my sisters who I think are wonderful mothers, they apologize to their kids.
就像我很诚实，你知道，我的两个姐姐，我都觉得她们是出色的母亲，她们会向自己的孩子道歉。
They say, I screwed up this time or I'm not gonna get everything right.
她们会说，我这次搞砸了，或者我不可能每件事都做对。
I'm waiting in it.
我在摸索中前进。
I'm trying to figure this out as we go.
我正在努力边走边弄明白这一切。
So I'm really sorry, I think I misjudged that one.
所以我真的很抱歉，我想我那次判断失误了。
And I think that's the best thing you can do as a parent.
我觉得这是你能作为一个父母做的最好的事。
That's the best thing you can do.
那是你能做出的最好举动。
That is very much what I tell my nanny to tell my kids.
这正是我告诉我的保姆转告我孩子们的话。
I don't really spend much time with my kids.
我其实并没有花太多时间陪我的孩子。
That's a joke.
开玩笑的。
开玩笑的啦。
You're dad really screwed up this time.
你们的老爸这次真的搞砸了。
When he's back from his yacht trip, he's going to take you for ice cream.
等他游艇旅行回来后，他会带你们去吃冰淇淋。
No, that's the best thing you can show your kids, that level of honesty, and I'm a human being and I think future Ted's a good dad for doing that, and he may overshare at times, but I do think that showing your kid that you're a human being is huge because then they get to be too, and that's a gift.
不，这是你能向孩子们展示的最好的事情，那种诚实的程度，我是一个活生生的人，我觉得未来的泰德因为这么做而成为一个好爸爸，他有时可能会分享过多，但我确实认为向你的孩子展示你是一个有人情味的人至关重要，因为这样他们也能成为有人情味的人，而这是一种馈赠。
Now we've reached the final act of our episode and something we like to do.
现在我们迎来了本集的最后一个环节，也是我们喜欢做的事情。
On this last part of the episode is read one of the many astonishingly beautiful letters that we receive.
在本集的最后一部分，我们要朗读一封我们收到的令人惊叹的美丽信件。
We love these.
我们太喜欢这些信了。
How we made your mother.
老爸老妈浪漫史。
Yeah, they're so good.
是的，它们太棒了。
So if you would like, again, a reminder, if you'd like to send us a letter, let us know what the show is meant to you, what your relationship is with the show, or you can write us a letter, You can record an audio, but go to how we made your mother.com.
所以如果你愿意的话，再次提醒一下，如果你想给我们写信，让我们知道这部剧对你意味着什么，你与这部剧的关系是什么，或者你可以给我们写信，你可以录制音频，但请访问 howwemedyourmother.com。
Go to contact and follow the instructions there.
点击联系页面并按照那里的说明操作。
Should be pretty clear.
这应该挺清楚的。
Today's letter is from Shiwon.
今天的信来自始温。
Hi, my name's Shiwon.
嗨，我叫始温。
I'm 23 years old and I'm from North Wales, although I'm currently living in London.
我23岁，来自北威尔士，不过目前住在伦敦。
I've been thinking about what to say here since the podcast came out, but now I have something I really wanna say.
自从这个播客开播以来，我一直在考虑该在这里说些什么，但现在我真的有话想说。
Trust the process here.
相信这个过程吧。
I don't remember when I first started watching him.
我不记得自己是什么时候开始看他的。
They used to air on E4, a British TV channel, when I just started exploring grownup TV for myself.
当时英国电视频道E4经常播出，那时我刚开始探索适合成年人看的电视节目。
So I must have been around 9 or 10 years old.
所以我当时大概9、10岁左右。
It's a little young to watch a show, but that's fine.
看这个节目有点太小了，不过没关系。
But it's safe to say, I don't remember not watching him.
但可以肯定的是，我不记得自己有过不看他的日子。
For years, I wanted to be a news reporter like Robin, and then I wanted to be a judge like Marshall.
多年来，我想成为像罗宾那样的新闻记者，后来又想成为像马歇尔那样的法官。
Around the time the podcast first came out, I was applying for a master's course in screenwriting.
就在这个播客刚开播的时候，我正在申请编剧专业的硕士课程。
I'd been offered an interview and was preparing for it.
我当时已经获得了面试通知，并正在为此做准备。
I was listening to the podcast.
我在听这个播客。
I heard Josh talk about the Kierkegaard quote about only being able to live your life forwards and a penny dropped.
我听到乔什谈到克尔凯郭尔的那句名言，大意是生活只能向前看，然后我突然恍然大悟。
I can't tell you how much that resonated with me.
我无法形容这句话对我的触动有多深。
Growing up watching him, yum, call it nature or nurture, I found myself to be a person who looks obsessively for signs from the universe and tries her best to romanticize reality.
从小看着他长大，嗯，不管是天性还是后天培养，我发现自己是一个执着于寻找宇宙讯号并竭尽全力将现实浪漫化的人。
I actually used the Kierkegaard, Josh, quote.
乔什，我真的引用了克尔凯郭尔的话。
I'm glad I'm getting credited for this quote in my interview.
我很庆幸能在面试中因引用这句话而受到肯定。
Thank you, Josh.
谢谢你，乔什。
And I found out today that I got in.
而我今天得知我被录取了。
All right, congrats.
好吧，恭喜。
Masters courses and Danish philosophers aside, Hemium has played a really big role in my life from when I'd watch episodes on E4 to when I began to collect the DVDs at age 12 to now my 20s.
抛开硕士课程和丹麦哲学家不谈，从我在E4上看剧，到12岁开始收集DVD，再到如今二十多岁的我，这档节目在我的人生中扮演了非常重要的角色。
I wasn't the happiest of teenagers, but here was this show that taught me to trust the process of my life, to look for signs from the universe and to romanticize everything in my life from the good to the really crappy, because those were the things that shaped my story.
我并不是一个最快乐的青少年，但就是有这样一部剧，它教导我要相信人生的进程，去寻找来自宇宙的讯号，并将我生活中的一切——从美好的到极其糟糕的——都浪漫化，因为正是这些东西塑造了我的故事。
At my lowest, I'll still go back to find a speech of Ted's to ground me.
在我处于人生低谷时，我依然会回去找一段泰德的演讲来让自己重回脚踏实地的状态。
And whenever I see a yellow umbrella in the wild, I take it as a sign to keep trusting the process.
每当我在生活中偶然看到一把黄伞，我都把它当作一个信号，提醒自己继续相信这个过程。
So thank you.
所以，谢谢你们。
For a wonderful show that has taught me and so many others that simply, everything will be okay.
感谢这部精彩的节目，它教会了我以及许多其他人一个简单的道理：一切都会好起来的。
Thanks for this podcast and its help with master's interviews, love from the other side of the Atlantic Shiwon, aspiring screenwriter, no longer aspiring judge.
感谢这个播客以及它对硕士面试的帮助，来自大西洋另一端的爱，始温，立志成为编剧，不再立志成为法官。
Fantastic.
太棒了。
Congratulations.
恭喜。
That's the best.
这真是太棒了。
I love everything about that.
我喜欢这一切。
Romanticized reality.
浪漫化的现实。
I like that phrase.
我喜欢这个短语。
And, you know, it's a lot of what it's a lot of what we were talking about, you know, like, I think to have a show where everything works out and people just keep going from success to success to success feels really dishonest.
而且，你知道的，这很大程度上就是我们一直在谈论的，你知道的，比如，我认为如果有一部剧，里面的事情总是圆满解决，人们总是一个接一个地走向成功，这会让人觉得很不真实。
And, and we were trying to, we were trying to make an honest show.
而且，我们一直试图制作一部真实的剧集。
I am guilty, please equip me, all sins are forgiven, a new York City.
我有罪，请给我定罪，所有罪孽都已被原谅，这里是纽约市。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《老爸老妈的浪漫史》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
本节目由我亚历克·莱夫制作，我们的联合制作人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios, and our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是“蓝色之点”工作室的亚历克斯·里夫斯，我们的数字内容制作人，也就是Z世代大师，是艾米莉·布隆伯格。
Artwork by John Morrow.
插图由约翰·莫罗创作。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这确实对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是由我们自己的乔什·拉德纳创作的《纽约市》，附加音乐由克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基提供。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢萝拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajormother.com to sign up for our sub-stack mailing list and for links to our social media.
访问 HowWeMajormother.com 注册我们的 Substack 邮件列表并获取我们的社交媒体链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您也可以点击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是本节目的重要组成部分。
Want some merch?
想要一些周边商品吗？
Click on the store link or go to howyougetyourmerch.com.
点击商店链接或访问 howyougetyourmerch.com。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack, order Craig Thomas' debut novel at CraigThomasRider.com slash novel, and you could subscribe to my dead father's society also on substack.
在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳的 Muse Letters，在 CraigThomasRider.com/novel 上订购克雷格·托马斯的首部小说，您还可以在 Substack 上订阅我的死去的父亲协会。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital heart disease research.
要了解如何做出改变，即本节目为先天性心脏病研究筹款的持续活动。
Check out the make a difference tab at the top of our website.
请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”标签页。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures.
本集节目由“后院风投”倾力支持。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞的。